on this week's episode of GameSpot after
dark we talk about GDC getting canceled
PAX East demos and really bad fanfiction
time stamps are in the description
[Music]
hello and welcome to GameSpot after dark
game spots unofficial official but still
official video game podcast that's us
I'm Callie I'm subbing in for Jake
Decker today and joining me is Michael
hi um hello it's been a while since I've
been here and it feels good cuz I have a
lot to talk about
Oh y'all back I'm ready to listen to my
Adama ass okay
our very own Ashley OH joining us from
New York hello and Curtin Davina hi the
illustrious the incredible the
irreplaceable oh look at that boots
though the great greetings and
salutations I'm Kurt and I'm very happy
to be with you all I'm gonna leave now
okay I'm gonna stay hi
because we have so many new ish and very
new faces we're gonna do even here once
one time well you weren't here for Chris
from Dayton Ohio the two points series
we're now on two point three thanks to
Kevin in our emails so how this works is
Chris from Dayton Ohio I'll just tell
the origin story again one sent us an
email that was like at the very
beginning of the podcast and was like
hey with all due respect I don't know
the who the [ __ ] any of you are and what
can you tell can you tell us about
yourselves and so we do this with
everybody who joins podcast so because
you guys have done that Chris from
Dayton Ohio standard segment talking
about the games you like etc well
actually do that and then we'll get a
special new 2.0 series yeah I haven't I
haven't played the update yet yeah
there's a new update so much notes yeah
passionates came through so Ashley the
first question is what do you do and
also what games do you like and are
there any like what's your favorite
stuff and yeah what would I do at
GameSpot yeah I'm the senior social
producer I look after Twitter god help
me
game set I really like I love love final
thing
I will never stop talking about Final
Fantasy 8 every year
no expletives there nice I'm playing
that I will always go back to overwatch
no matter what
I kind of hate myself because I buy 5
new games and then keep playing
overwatch but you know you work hard not
to know we you know yeah and working my
way through Yakuza kuma number 2 I spent
so much time in that game doing just the
Cabaret stuff everything should be its
own game I love that so much kind of
like zero I was with a Sayed because I
started with zero and zero is mine so
hard to top zero zeros a perfect game I
I saw your tweet
would you consider agree with that
perfect game not my favorite of all time
but it is a perfect game you know saying
mm-hmm
as the reviews legally obligated to say
there's no such thing as a perfect thing
as a perfect game but in my heart y'all
can't see my heart that's but it's just
a Cuza zero yeah not Yakuza Yakuza got a
got 8k that's right
Yakuza anyway example um kevin has come
through with the patch notes first he
says hey after dark crew thank you so
much for the kind words on the new baby
just had a new baby
Congrats Kevin Oh sadly I did not grow
up in West Hartford but my wife did and
she does not remember Connecticut last
episode Conrad hi all the way she says
all right so I'm gonna do the questions
first and then we'll read the patch
notes because the patch notes are always
very entertaining he freezes them just
like regular game patch notes so alright
so how this is gonna work is I'll read
the question and then one by one you
guys answer as quickly as you can
Michael's doin his surprise burps yo
have some drinks
[ __ ] me up man anyway so I'll just go
and then we're gonna fire right yeah
it's like the first just all right
what's your hurt okay ready in mmo's DPS
healer or tank DPS healer peeler in
Pokemon grass fire or water starter fire
fire grass Sonic or Mario Mario Mario
Mario
life is strange walking dead gone home
or what remains of youth Finch gone home
what remains to be the Finch gone home
game that made you the angriest maybe
the angriest ah I don't get angry you
very much you can't shotgun that's a
quick like there's that call of duty
black ops because I got shot back a lot
uh all out for do not like at all
oh wow audio levels spiking sorry
actually I'm having a lot of trouble
with this Lake here don't your names
last time you ain't I'm intense angry
I bought some six no no I was like nah
my patient with that game i I I don't I
don't know uh I don't know
I don't think I have an answer I'd
rather I get mad I stop all episode mad
my answer remains destiny
Mortal Kombat are Street Fighter Street
Fighter Mortal Kombat halo overwatch
quake siege or Call of Duty Oh
halo quake one most desired smash
Ultimate Edition who who do you want in
smash Ultimate Edition I thought you
meant like especially like collector's
edition like cool what's uh addition
that it's um what I want in the game
cosmic ear you that's what Johnny said
ah damn
Tom Nook Oh Frances York Morgan he's on
switch now he's early on Kennedy I have
like a I have a move set for Leon
Kennedy like all this just gun wall so I
mean so resonable for specifically like
one of the best things to do when you
get the infinite rocket launcher it's
like if you shoot at the ground in front
of you you never get hurt by he just as
a sweet stance to block himself from it
but it's always a really quick way to
get through enemies I just would love
like I mean actually snake has it it's
just the rock wanted to the ground bees
down be yeah and also like his sick ass
suplex moves and like he's just from
basically resi before moves all the way
give me like a QuickTime event one
that'd be sweet linear or open world
open world I guess linear I think I
might have a vote linear in FPS games
pistol shotgun SMG assault rifle sniper
rifle or melee for PC sniper rifle if
I'm playing console with an assault
rifle that's good that's good you can't
do this to me it depends it depends
yeah it really depends because some shot
ease or just shotguns way better than
some games and horrible and others yeah
if you're for me if I'm in a super
difficult mode like the shotgun sort of
is like a one and done situation but if
you have ammo to spare I mean absolutely
assault rifle I think I would I think I
would I think I naturally would go
assault rifles like machine guns just
like brown boys even as a SMG that one
the one that's like I'm good with that
guy but I am I am fond to shot ease so
this is the most discussion we've had on
this role depends on the game like apex
I would go salt rifle but yeah some
games you might go shot e some games
better yeah yeah yeah it depends if it's
hit scanner ballista shoot oh wow true
co-op single-player or multiplayer
single-player I don't play with none of
y'all yeah
that single-player single-player co-op
just get stressed oh thank you
I think basically everyone has it
single-player so far Xbox Playstation
and tend to a PC or oh yeah best
commentary on Ouya we've had oh is a
little cube box last for a second it was
a big deal for indie devs I feel like
when it first came out at stuff I think
this I don't like this question because
I'd probably go PC even though wearing a
PlayStation sweater you know the vibes
Virtual Boy they were controller ever I
PI say I don't know Dual Shock 4 is on
point
sure yeah sure hmm I'm gonna go
Dreamcast
I love pop-tarts our toaster strudel
toaster strudel for sure I do now I'll
put the low icing on that thing oh [ __ ]
I know my morning is gonna be good if I
had to touch the food and a nice iced
coffee this is morning routine I just
heard your morning routine yeah yeah I
know when you have a good day
yeah I'm gonna go with strawberry
pop-tarts yeah it's pretty good
untoasted on frosted strawberry
pop-tarts that's not still s'mores
pop-tarts yeah um is it cheating if you
use an in-game trick or exploit to
trivialize a boss what what is it what
is it cheating is it cheating
uh yeah I think so but I'm fine with it
it's not a big deal you cheat in a game
[Laughter]
relax
well I mean at least he said in a game
yeah vicen you said yes yes I don't care
is it cheating if you save scum know
what it's part of the game it depends on
the game and well no it's I would say no
it's not cheating like if you just cause
it's just cheap just like it just takes
you out of say it's no like if you play
like dishonored and you see a guard
patrol and you keep trying and trying to
get it perfect you just keep reloading
yeah that's good I think that's a play
style oh that is not cheating trophy
yeah I would say it's like it's
definitely a thrill to try and play a
certain way so that's like cheating but
I guarantee you it doesn't feel like
that cuz it's a lot of work yes yeah
yeah it's the emotional cheating of
video games coming to Michael Wow whoa
that's still cheating yeah you said I
say he's got me cheating no no emotional
cheating things coming it's totally
Jeff keel ear Jeff Gerstmann oh boy Jeff
Gerstmann man why didn't we ever talk
about this man it's my guy I mean no
offense Jeff Keely he's good at what he
does
I think but you know my boy Jeff
Chrisman is out there
sure yes sure I'm gonna vote kurtzman
because I've met him and interviewed him
recently so I haven't met Kili so I
can't make that judgment
I mean Jeff is just he's just right over
there I know but I actually I know but I
had the opportunity actually like pull
him aside and interview him for you sure
if you if you listen to the latest bomb
cast
he's wiling he is he's got some [ __ ] to
say about gamers anyway game on a couch
desk bed or beanbag chair this is
subjective man would you say would you
rather game on a couch desk bed or a
beanbag chair on a deadly like I've
really come to appreciate what it's like
to play game sitting on a couch because
I set out a desk all day and I don't
want to go home and sit at another desk
so I'd rather sit on the couch I wish I
had a beanbag chair so beanbag chair yo
I had enormous beanbag chair at my last
apartment when I had the space to have
one and it was my it was my second home
and it's almost frustrating I can't play
games in that thing
in my current apartment you sell it I
moved from one coast to the other did
you sell it I had well actually no it's
in the hands of my best friend oh and
now it's pretty much belongs to his
three dogs but still yeah they probably
ate that [ __ ] but I get to see pictures
of ever so often be I love you too more
okay favorite gaming snack Oh jalapeno
cheddar Cheetos specific you're gonna
get [ __ ] all over your chopsticks baby
hell yeah no buds
Haribo cherries uh-huh clean clean
snacking mm-hmm it's true Totino's
and twin snake Haribo twin snakes gummy
worms those are like the goatee yeah
damn okay I eat them I don't I don't
separate those things by the way I eat a
whole so yeah risky check off the serial
killer list eats pop-tarts frosted
pop-tarts I eat both twin snakes at once
and yeah you [ __ ] bet your ass I eat
the cheese stick you know no time it's
just deep throating yeah it just takes
too long just peeling shame by string
okay last question I'm unapologetic ass
sorry horrible this next question the
last one has gotten comically long as
about video game art whirs ooh Miyazaki
Kamiya Matsu no Sakurai Hoshino Miyamoto
Kodaka
Kojima or cliffy B can I look at the
list again
I just daca agree with any of them is it
a like Hudson I want to choose one of
them I don't want to choose any of them
is it like Cott tsuruhachi no from Atlas
yeah I got concert Hofstra house you
know cuz cuz you know the vibes sure
Kodaka song sweary if I can't use it if
I can't use weary I'm gonna choose
cliffy B anyway I want to read his book
the curse from Dayton Ohio 2.3 I do want
to read his patch notes because some of
these questions were brand new to me
he says question 10 added pistol and
melee to accommodate destiny overwatch
an exceptionally annoying Call of Duty
players question 14 pop-tarts or toaster
strudel is a deeply spiritual and
personal question to me and I would like
to leave it as is it is also a reference
to the easy alleys podcast where they
pick games that are there pop-tarts are
total strudel toaster
screw dolls if a game grabs your heart
it's a pop-tart if the game will be
brewing it's a toaster strudel don't
know about that question 15 retired
cheating is it cheating if a friend
tells you and replaced it with a
hopefully harder question it was because
literally no one said that it was
cheating if a friend tells you question
17 retired o'dwyer or Riker is only one
person ever picked poor Dan or I curtain
that add new choices that's the Jeffers
Jeff question only dance question 18
added more gaming location options by
podcaster request an added and question
20 added mutts no and how she know after
influencer right and campaign
I'm very entertained by the yeah yeah
thank you Kevin and way to go Kevin
original email Chris from Dayton Ohio
now we can move on to what we've been
playing or doing uh Ashley since you're
new to the San Francisco office for this
week
we'll start with you what happened to so
I've been playing a lot of Witcher 3
I've never played Witcher games but
Jake's not hosting today oh really you
should tell me you hate it I like what
Jake is - The Witcher 3 is what you are
- fine fine seeing oh that's dangerous
maybe I shouldn't mention Frodo
I get like I just start yelling up
someone says like okay nevermind he's
not like that
but it would be really funny if you told
him how much you hated The Witcher so
anyway you've been playing the piece
yeah so I play it I started playing
after I saw the show it was $15 on PSN
so how can you say no to that I was kind
of hesitant at first because I'm not a
super open world game person like I feel
like either I get bored or it makes me
very anxious so this one is kind of I
think like horizon zero dawn was super
good at that so it kind of like nailed
the in-between so for which I got kind
of nervous because the beginning was
like a little bit hard but now I'm at
the point where like I know exactly
where to go when I want to kill people
and get a ham sandwich or get a grilled
chicken sandwich and that kind of makes
it worth it but I do think that like
it's janking
first it was frustrating for me but now
I think it kind of adds to the charm in
a way that like I don't have have you
guys put the picture oh yeah okay so you
know when there's a there's like an inn
like infested area you you kill all the
goblins or whatever and then people you
know return it but I find this really
weird because I just I killed a whole
horde of these like really just
crazy-looking things and then
immediately the screen just goes to
three people striding like like a cowboy
man on Twitter I'm just gonna say that
and hope you know what I'm talking about
but I'm creating a way cooler image may
be good the two cowboy men walking
side-by-side you talk about that one I
don't know one dude that looks like
you're slick you're skiing it looks like
you're what's the skiing that's not down
a hill yeah you're doing oh well Cowboys
in cross-country skiing it's weird
because the the or you know it'll be
infested by bandits whatever and then as
soon as I'm done killing the last one
like their corpses are still on the
ground and all these people just return
to those no like great like set up shop
and there's like an herbalist there's
like a dude who's like making armor and
then meanwhile I'm still running around
like well I didn't loot these bodies yet
but y'all just set up camp here so
you're just scrubbing through dead
bodies while it's pretty weird
picking up hay getting eggs from
chickens because that's what people do
in the farm way if anybody listening
knows of a mod for The Witcher 3 to get
rid of all the vomiting in the cities
that would be dope vomiting like
vomiting like yeah noises that's the
thing I couldn't deal with wouldn't so
when I was sprinting through a city it's
like I get that they're trying to be
like oh he's Witcher and he has crazy
sense of hearing but it's also like I am
sprinting through this city and yet in
like really loudly on one side someone's
like hacking up phlegm you're just like
San Francisco I
it's so loud and I kind of like is there
no option to turn down the mucus noise
see if so if you know of a mod for mouth
and bodily function noises to eliminate
those in the winter 3 we'd all greatly
benefit I think so there's still no mod
for that I mean I haven't gone hunting I
don't know if it like he's effective I
don't know if it'll like cuz like Jake's
the one who likes setup oh said my game
for me and was like hey here's here's I
downloaded all the mods and like like he
set it all up so I was like okay so I
don't know if like if the mod would
contradict or counter indicate or
whatever with one of the other mods yeah
I don't know but if you have one I would
love it because I can't handle vomit in
it any and that's why I couldn't watch
The Witcher show Oh is there a line that
there were like three episodes
back-to-back with some vomit and that's
so when I just did another microphone I
was like that way that's why Michael
says to stop wow I know yeah big enough
are you liking it cuz like I found the
beginning of The Witcher 3 so hard to
get into because well first of all I was
like Geralt is the sexiest man alive and
I just couldn't get past that I was like
this is this undoes everything I thought
I knew about myself and I just don't
like that and then I got over that and
then I was like who's dandelion I don't
know what's going on who is this person
to this person and again I had to be
like so Jake what whose dandelion and
he's like oh okay well in the the books
you know so he's he's made a great video
on how to on how to properly consume
it's very cute witcher 3 yeah and so
like you know he'll be like oh well the
reason this is happening is because in
the last wish this happened
so it's i found that so hard to get into
and I don't know how I would have done
it without his help - like how did you
get through that
honestly I I thought that I was gonna
stop doing it because in the beginning
it was pretty difficult in that like
clearly my weapons and like my upgrades
were not enough and like I kept just
venturing into areas where I just like
get my ass handed to me which like kind
of you know that that's like sort of the
trap I felt with with other open world
games like Skyrim and like breath of the
wild I'd be like oh like this is cool I
didn't
explore this part of the map and then
like I die and lose like 20 minutes of
progress but other than that like after
getting over the initial hump like now
it's much easier that I like have all
the oils and have like better armor I
still don't know why I'm always over
encumbered I feel like I sell everything
and I always have that problem in games
I mean specifically in the witch right I
felt like I was constantly yeah but all
the time I was and the I thought the
inventory was a little like it's a lot
yeah there's there's like I think I
think Jake mentioned this in his video
were like there was a mod that changes
the oh yeah I can't do that on ps4
because it he said you bought it on ps4
yep so I think like part of us tough
with the ps4 I mean like it's clearly
from before because like there'll be a
weird lag and kind of he does this weird
sidestep when I'm like come over here
and loose this start body and like the
x2 loot disappears I'm like nope you're
stepping over no can you know now you're
just going around oh my god and then it
becomes and then I got like kind of like
motion sickness from like trying to get
this dude to just like just just get
just get the [ __ ] sandwich the dead
body
yeah off a dead body how do you think
and surprisingly so does dried fruit and
nuts oh well yeah I mean those are very
good if you have low blood sugar
so I get it but like compared to a
chicken like I don't know it just like
so much like how much protein / calories
is in this room
so I didn't know that game was as horny
as it was thought that it was just with
the bathtub scene which I was so happy I
was in the beginning of the game so we
got it out of the way but then once they
just like the thing with the unicorn I
was like okay well oh guys showed it and
like Keira Metz though Keira Metz is
just like she it I you know what I'm not
gonna say what I was gonna say which was
be [ __ ] she she her dress like leaves
nothing to the imagination I feel like
it's like there was supposed to be a
button in front or a zipper but she's
like nah [ __ ] it
and then
those boobs seekers he helped cover and
she's not even just pasties but there's
like special like adhesive bras that you
can wear with like low-cut dresses and
it's like Kim Kardashian loves wearing
that she duct tapes her boobs and she's
all doctors yeah and like Keira Metz
it's like you didn't even bother with
that her boobs just kind of like move
very distracting yeah it is extremely
distracting some people dictate duct
tape they're Wang's when they run
marathons
as a former marathon runner I've never
done that though why not I didn't I hit
you only people X Wow
I didn't mean to flex or a cell phone I
was a former marathon yeah well anyway
Kurt what do you hope that's it
is that all you got on The Witcher well
I'm duct taping my genitals something
that's all I got thank you so much you
don't wanna talk about coffee talk how
do you know oh wait it's cuz right yeah
you role-playing coffee talk that's the
game I'm playing I mean it's that about
that is that game resonates with me on
multiple levels I had okay first and
foremost I actually had a really tough
time buying the game because I was not
thrilled with the art style nothing
against Oh like the store was terrible
and you know I was going so coffee
talking on paper is a game that I like I
would love to play a lot of it stems to
the fact that I was a barista for many
many moons and I take pride and like
getting to know my customers and like
getting to know their stories in their
lives that's how I got my job at a
newspaper actually in Rochester in
Rochester home of the garbage point
let's talk by the way white haunts the
White House is a thing you know about
wait don't why is what do you mean your
friend I got man how do you not talk
like I don't talk like that because I'm
Curt yeah but you're not a [ __ ] her
cuz I'm not a
Creon not that every practice is great
by the way anyways I don't know why I
don't have that accent I don't know what
happened along the ways it may sneak out
it has more of that she's been
criticized for uh she says bagels I've
been criticized for how I say bagels
what it is a bagel no bait
Becky's like cackles wait what bagel
it's it's like I don't even know what
part of the country it is but I had to
train myself out of saying it because
I'm from LA I think it's not an LA thing
I don't know where I got yeah I think I
also had a speech impediment as a kid I
couldn't say my arse so I think I over
so imagine me saying Kurt court could
[Music]
exactly and that's you know I said that
once so just sound like I was English
and feel like what you trying to say
about English people and I was like cut
and they also don't see the t's at the
end of the word so it's just like cut up
my name is cat so it just sounds like a
kid and when I met one had good friends
hate and from the UK shout-out to Matt
Wells when I met him he was afraid to
say my name and person cuz he was just
like.he because he felt like it was like
a burp
he was just like and then here wait I
have another great story I went to ok so
first and foremost criticize me all you
want but we were tourists in London and
we were just I just need a coffee and I
went to a Starbucks people would you go
to Starbucks and one I'm just so where's
Lucy into him anyways so I went to
Starbucks and they were like what's your
name for the order as a Kurt and they're
like cut it skirt cut yes my name is cut
my name is cut and when I got my cup
it's at CU t cut yeah wild [ __ ] no I
would say no Ben kirtland I was being a
bloody beggar no yeah well you call me a
wrong in one so you know that I know
what man I thought it's like oh I'm just
like where's me peas bra view and mushy
peas you you've been wrong and we got ok
like three episodes of love island last
night
I'm ready to do the British accent thing
all day watch Peep Show it's one of the
greatest shows ever made
okay coffee talk so coffee talks is a
game about being a barista and basically
hearing the lives and stories of your
frickin cost customers horse came
through freaking customers and one of
the main kind of plot points is that
it's midnight it's a it's a it's a
coffee shop that's open at midnight in
Seattle specifically and of course
Seattle which I've lived there has this
whole aura thing it's always rainy and
spookiness a Seattle freeze and people
are just a little it's different
I am coffee's a big deal there so for me
it's checked off a lot of boxes like
coffee sick since the books is cut and
so probably like I hate all of you
you're all wrong a talent what where's
me peeves brough my peeps breath in it
but I had a problem the art style at
first so I like anime but there's a
certain kind of anime art style that
sometimes can be a bit derivative MLA I
don't know I couldn't tell you like
super cutesy
I mean I it's not no it's not like that
it's not it's it comes off like I don't
know who did the art in this game so I
don't want to offend anyone but it comes
off kind of like a like a tried and true
kind of Americanized anime art style
that doesn't I don't want to get jerk I
don't want to I don't want like [ __ ] on
anybody's liking of a certain art style
no I think I know what you mean like the
American take on yeah yeah I feel like
early Cartoon Network shows yeah so it
was it was a turn-off at first cuz like
a static is a huge part of games for me
and I was like I love everything about
the conception of this game the concepts
of this game but the art style is like
oh I see I get it
and I do still feel that way but the
game otherwise has it is like it ticks
us all the ticks the boxes it's kind of
like a very chill hip-hop loaf I like
that YouTube's signature chilled cow
yeah yeah soundtrack all the way through
it's got like a pretty kind of a similar
size to what that YouTube video like his
iconic for and you get to do lots a art
and serve drinks and it's just it's a
relaxing change of pace especially
because I've been playing through doom
on nightmare and for which [ __ ] to me
but I love that game but I do something
to the opposite and that game's been
feeling a good gap it's like a visual
novel style thing it's it's easy to
explain it that way because it is all
dialogue but it's it's it doesn't really
it's it's always from this one
perspective of characters coming into
this coffee shop and you just get to
hear their conversations and then
eventually kind of get to help them
sometimes work through choices in their
life
so it's a very slice of life visual
novel ask game where you get to make
them drinks and there's little get bits
that bring me back home I know Michael
you got something to say I'm watching
you twiddling those fingers but it's
good because for me as a barista when a
regular starts to come in they expect
you to remember their drink and I was
like I got you I know you want that
triple shots maybe that same feeling
green that green tea latte I know I got
it's always an honor when they know
you're drink it's also a little bit of
an attack when you don't it well chosen
go to I know when we go to honey baby
and though oh you want the bacon egg and
cheese I'm like yeah she's like okay
yeah I feel bad cuz whenever like I go
to equator and they know my order and
they know my name and sometimes when I
was like I'm not in the mood for Cortado
I just want like shot whoa whoa all this
press Oh or just like it's americano I
come up and they already have it select
on the screen I'm just like you know
what I'm getting it I'm getting the
Cortado I'm doing it what was it say is
have you played a bahala I was
a bartender is a similar thing but
bartending in a cyberpunk setting yeah
instead of coffee years so hey why can't
like the aesthetic thing is what kind of
gets me like the cyberpunk was actually
kind of a turn-off and you guys just
said that for Valhalla yeah but I gotta
check it out I see what it looks like I
gotta wait like it's like after-party
Ritchie loves I think more of like a
pointing I want that you just said point
collect much I think it's very word on
the street is it's very good mmm
I haven't come down from disco easy me
to be honest I've just been trying to
fill that gap is so good be it three
times
Wow anyway I have time to do that I
guess Michael I next I'm getting nervous
I'm a crimes podcast I know that you
went to pass we'll talk about your
package period later so what everything
for fun when I've had times have fun so
the last time was on this podcast I had
talked about trails of Cold Steel one
and I was at the end of that game and
since then I had finished trails of Cold
Steel one and start went right into
strip trails of cold co2 and coal cl2
picks up right where one leaves off but
I need to kind of talk through I need to
get my get the [ __ ] off my chest about
the ending of Cold Steel because it's
such a name it's a great in capital
encapsulation of everything that game
does so great and so if you don't know
what cold someone here's the elevator
pitch it's kind of like military school
it's sort of like persona and you have
social links with your friends and you
go on educational field trips and all
that stuff but you kind of you're you're
young ends in a conspiracy and not
conspiracy but like a lot of military
drama political drama and this military
academy is kind of like the person most
prestigious Academy in the country and
there's a reason why all of your
classmates have been selected
specifically for this special class and
all that all of that makes sense
throughout the game but the ending of
Cold Steel won the file chapter kicks
off with the school festival and
everyone's
yeah happy having fun and it's very
delightful and I the favorite my
favorite thing about how Cold Steel does
the school festival is that there are
actual minigames that you go to how many
yakisoba stands are there there's a lot
there's a lot and there's a lot a lot of
food stands in there and there's like
noodle there's a noodle stand as ice
cream and all that stuff and it's it's
so delightful but the thing is like
throughout all of Cold Steel 1 there is
like tension brewing underneath like
with the high like the everyone who's in
power and of course like these kids
being like on the verge of joining the
military and being high-ranking officers
like that's what they're working for
they're like pawns in the scheme but
they're they also are wrecking like
they're cognizant of that but there's
like this this delightful thing about
going through the school festival
knowing something's brewing underneath
and school festival ends and it kind of
hits you with like yes the thing that
you thought was coming is coming so coal
steel never hits you with like cheap
plot twists and I really appreciate that
and it was like it was just such a such
an odd feeling to have a game be so
upfront about what is trying to tell you
which is very refreshing for JRPGs and
like the plot twists the thing I love
about cold Steel's that it's characters
are smart all right like we're gonna you
gather dude like I hate it when
characters like oh I never saw that
coming oh my god I can't believe your
own face just did it yeah I can't
believe betrayed us like I can't believe
I've been betrayed by my best friend and
I when the plots was hits all the
characters kind of like wait for reals
like let's walk through why this would
happen and they're like nah nah nah
don't remember this one thing I'm like
the character dialogue walks you through
what happens and why it happens and that
makes the characters really smart but
also makes whatever is happening at the
game extremely clear and the end of coal
seal 1 like it's kind of Wims it like
the whole game is kind of whimsical it's
kind of like yo whimsy that's that's my
word it's kind of cute it leans into
like the ho Oh like we're
cool anime girls and anime boys and then
it like at the very end it [ __ ] flips
the script and says we're not a girls
word a [ __ ] civil war bro this is
breaking out and the thing jumping
straight into cold steel to is like
these characters grow up fast and I love
how that's reflective of how they talk
what they talk about how they carry
themselves and it's very refreshing for
a game that you look at it it's like oh
this is like some anime [ __ ] cold
stares games
honestly that sounds like Fantasy 8 yeah
yeah sword guns yeah yeah it's like [ __ ]
is happening and you're like well yeah
now that you mention it all of its anime
[ __ ] yeah is that what we said is
what they said
and what's better than that oh ok but I
love the characters and how they're
written like this the the I'm very
impressed with how cold steel is like
written on the front and I'm playing
another game right now that it's really
weird to play different JRPGs
simultaneously and realize how it makes
me appreciate coal steel a lot a lot
more and the opening the opening movie
the cold steel - yo I get mad emotional
because like that is like one of the
best affiliate motional right now you
know I'm saying any [ __ ] right do you
love your pairing your drink pairings
ooh you're you do on Twitter you like
peridot I had a cold steel reserve
trails of cold steel reserve yeah and
then I'm playing this aw I'm gonna talk
about chosen sky in a minute and I had
trail I had Skyy Vodka
so trails in the sky but you know I'm
saying I think that's my favorite part
about cuz when you pair drinks yeah
with games oh damn you bet what time
line is fire bro hey y'all don't follow
me on twitter [ __ ] but uh yeah coal co2
is opening like the opening movie that
song is very good the vote the vocals
are very great and it's very great it's
it's just there's so much passion and so
so much emphasis and you just feel
emotional from the middle opening song
and sounds whimsical yeah my those those
are my boys and girls and so when I
finished cold steel one
I started trails in the sky I don't
think I want to explain the connection
between them but actually well real
quick cold feels a four-part series
trails in the skies the three-part
series trails this guy happens before
coldsteel but then trails in the sky
ends up catching up or they start to
intertwine the stories once you get too
cold seal three cool oh and I'm not
there yet but I'm playing trails in the
sky and Charles the sky is also very
whimsical it's like a very it's a
delightful game it's it's much older but
I love that game too like the main
characters fell bright is she's like one
of it she's that knucklehead
[Music]
stereotype that trope but very good one
of those and yeah that game is also girl
like like fight yeah yeah what's that
there's a word for that like the tomboy
kind of trope oh yeah yes sweet and her
what you know what is kind of weird but
I guess the game will come around on it
is that show so she has her brother
adopted brother this is a soap opera
dude yeah she's like 12 and they're both
12 and then her father ended up adopting
this dude who was 12 and then they end
up growing up together there's some
tension there like they want to smash we
our oldest guys trail this guy is great
I'm almost done with that game but I you
need to put it off wait did you like it
did you did you enjoy it okay this is
anyway mmm those good I can't I have
been playing a little game called murder
by numbers a pick cross murder mystery
game what wait is it related to pick
cross or is it like pick Ross it's like
you use so basically the structure of
the game is its part visual novel so you
play like a this is like this is very
curtain this is like the old lady in me
who just loves to sit at home and watch
murder mysteries like I will pick cross
so I'm having a great time I am planning
to have a review up on gamespot so we'll
see how that goes I have a lot of [ __ ]
going on um but the gist of the game is
like it's set in 1996 you play like the
character like you represent is an
actress on a like a cult favorite murder
show called murder mystery and the other
you're like coworker actress is she
plays Miss Terry and she's like the star
and the way you solve there's been a
murder
obviously and you do this like your have
like a companion robot who's really cute
what what I don't know no I mean I was
like I was like I was like yeah Murder
She Wrote Angela Lansbury let's get in
that old people thing and then robot
when does it take place six robot like a
fax machine with a personality that's a
fax machine with a personality yeah it's
like yes basically the robot thing
his name is scout and he's really cute
he doesn't like his memory drives had
been corrupted so he doesn't know what
his purposes are why he's been created
but he has a scan feature so you can
scan the environment to find it's it's
so like a point-and-click sort of thing
you scan you click on a thing and then
it
up a pick cross puzzle from there the
image you get from the pick cross if you
don't know what pick crosses it's like a
it's a Sudoku adjacent I guess if that's
the most similar touchstone puzzle and
the puzzles form pictures and so when
you do the putty when you complete a
puzzle and murder by numbers you get
like a picture of an object and then
it's like oh you found you know your car
keys or you found because the first
puzzle the tutorial puzzle is finding
your car keys and I'm really enjoying it
I really like the integration of pick
cross with story and I like the way that
the the murder mystery is unfolding it's
one of those that it's like like it's
you know classic murder mystery or it's
like you think you've got it solved and
then there's a new element introduced
that changes everything
are you playing it on switch yeah so I
am having fun with that it's very much a
me kind of game that is the [ __ ] I do
like I'm all over everything you said
fax machine with a personality I love
this robot so much not like like Clippy
is it no what is that what is clippie
yeah no no it's more like a like because
you play a detective you're your
character is the detective on this this
popular show show and he sees you and
it's like you're a detective can you
help me find like I don't know who I am
or I need to find somebody who can like
figure out who I am basically he says it
way cuter than that and then you're like
I'm actually not like I'm not like a
real detective I'm a detective on te but
then it you got to put your detective
hat on because someone's murdered so of
course and there is like a bonafide
himbo like what is that again you
explained it before I suppose to Michael
already said Frank and you thought Shrek
was a him but I forgot why
since it sounds like a male member megin
oh really like Tom attractive really
dumb is not a himbo Critic Chris
Hemsworth in the Ghostbusters movie is a
himbo
Shrek adjacent shrek is not him Bo he's
also tricks not Tom right yeah like
donkey is more is closer to him
doggy yeah because he's so hot he pulled
the Dragons away no way almost wanna say
that Yugi from persona 5 is but he's not
like muscular almost just very dumb you
just got strong dumbass Jordan and I
were trying to come up with anime him
busy him Bo have to be a like a desert
hambo have to be a meathead no I think
I'm speaking like I know like I've heard
him Bo before this but imagine like I
imagined I imagine him Bo just being
like the archetype of like oh they're an
attractive person
they're an attractive like classically
handsome a convicted person and then
when you speak to them when you when you
hear them speak them over they open
their mouths like you dumb yeah cool so
all this time you're threatened everyone
around him exactly threatening is this
like an eatable point that you have we
have shrek is life on the internet shrek
is life is a video of someone describing
a fateful encounter is through the
window and make sweet sweet loved this
is a sincere oh really
it's like shrek is love shrek shrek is
this line fiction that someone wrote and
they're narrating or is this something
they wanted it is a narrated fanfiction
kind of in the vein it's like animated
kind of like half life full life
consequences please tell me you've seen
half life full life gods no oh and I'm a
huge fan
live consequence you have oh my god
about about Gordon Freeman's brother
oh is this is like bowing you lose the
halo what's the halo one Master Chief's
brother Joe Chi halos in space is my
ultimate favorite bad fanfiction it's
like 300 words and then and the opening
line is Joe chief was in space and then
my second favorite bad fanfiction is
doom repercussions of evil give it I
want it so there's so much to teach you
I'm also like innocent I really don't
have an excuse I have no idea I just
like I just think shrek and then I think
Smash Mouth and then I think Guy Fieri
and it's just like a wormhole that just
keeps going sure Kyle like he's a Chef
Boyardee
it's Guy Fieri yeah Times Square yes
flavor - its guy for Yeti I'm gonna
stick that to the grave
an accident on flavortown yeah how do
you say secretary flavortown because I'm
Italian work exactly the way it's guys
Yeti flavor Villa can we give them Chef
Boyardee British people pronounce it a D
- okay yeah that's true what they don't
say adidas they say a Dida no they don't
yeah yes no they don't em how do you
damn are you in there are you the boy
cigar there I need a squeeze burst into
the oh my oh yes yeah damn yeah
they also say Mike Mike no they don't
yeah but that's how I'm tempted yeah
yeah yeah
yike anyway we should probably move on
to the topics Berta by numbers those
yeah it's not out yet not as of this
recording mmm-hmm
I don't know I don't I don't think
embargo but another really safe because
I operate him in embargoes yes okay so
we should start with the news the first
thing is that GDC was postponed until
sometime this summer effectively
canceled GCC was gonna take place very
very soon in San Francisco and due to
coronavirus concerns has been I want to
say indefinitely postponed just because
they said later this summer didn't give
it at the same time I'm like summer you
got III you got comic-con you got game
tax west packs west and you got TGS
shortly after that there's a lot of
stuff going on in summer so it's I mean
it's it's a bummer I really like GDC for
like for my job I like being able to
check out cool indie games like one of
the first not one of the first GD C's
but a game that was really well received
that I first saw at GDC was like what
the golf oh yeah or untitled goose game
like like smaller games that yeah if
people didn't get to see those demos
might not even know about I saw I did a
one-hour Dreams demo at GDC and I like
that changed my perspective on the game
dreams I think it was just so impressive
and so I do I'm sad that we won't be
having that this year I'm personally
pretty hurt by it because shout out to
Rochester again but they were gonna have
a big New York State game dev like oh
thing there and I was able to see a lot
of my friends and people who are part of
like the smaller industry on the other
side yeah so it sucks I mean there's a
lot of people who students included who
like this is an opportunity for them to
commit to something and meet people show
something they're working on do
post-mortems that help the entire
industry yeah it's it's a huge it sees
your networking event and
like when Microsoft and epic pulled out
I was like wow that's that's probably
the bit that were the biggest hits
because like we have we see a lot of
independent games during GDC we're able
to because everyone's here and it's in
our back yard but like they interface
with Microsoft because the ID at Xbox
and then Unreal Engine is very important
for them to interface with epic because
of that but a lot of the independent
developer or maybe not a lot but there
are a lot of independent developers who
are still going to be in San Francisco
because they're like damn man like
there's no benefit maybe there's no
benefit to them like cancelling all
their plants they make so expensive yeah
look if they're gonna try and do this
thing in the summer I don't know where
the [ __ ] is gonna be there because yeah
there's the the meat of GDC I think is
the independent developers and for them
to get support from the bigger company
yeah who are there i watch so i watched
a lot of your videos last year for the
mix yeah before worked here just like
the rotation of talking to and stuff
like that and I and I think that's how I
think I also watched your coverage of
like stadia at that point - oh yeah that
was one of the big things yeah that
makes me wonder like wait like what
things
I mean GDC is usually not a place for
huge announcements but I'm curious about
stuff like that that we're still we're
still having we're still doing the indie
mix we're still doing the mix with the
independent media exchange I think
that's what's called shows it to my boy
Justin Woodward
it's from southeast San Diego you know
the vibes we're still doing that and
like the cool thing about that is we got
to do we have like a long list of games
like hey we're gonna have the devs on
the livestream it's hard to pick six we
pick six and then have them on stream
but I want to see I want to see all of
them well most of them are gonna be here
so at least we'll still have that we'll
still have coverage of games during that
week so I'll be uh I'll be doing that
showing y'all what's up with some of
those games but the mixed event is still
happening - how's that going to go down
this time around are you gonna have a
mini in office yeah yeah we're still
gonna like do a livestream okay here
cool cool cool
but yeah it's stay tuned for that I mean
personally it's kinda like oh I went to
PAX East so I got to see a lot of the
people that I usually see at these
events
yeah cool but still like GC is a it's if
yo GDC is expensive to like get
expensive
man sure more than you would expect it's
bad it's it's a pretty big deal for the
people who making theirs always cool
panels like their panels that like I
wouldn't understand there's like super
development heavy panels but there's
also just like oh narrative design with
you know and then like it won't be like
you know narrative design around mental
health or yeah like really cool
interesting things that like we were
totally before it was canceled slash
postponed
we had like a spreadsheet that was like
okay here's all the cool panels like
look at them and see what you're
interested in which we do for for these
kinds of events and I was really looking
forward to that kind of thing because
it's like that's your opportunity to do
that yeah I mean we it's an opportunity
for us who makes shows and to meet
people and organize possibilities for
episodes and certain things and then
you're expected to be in a certain quota
in the industry at least it's like it's
a lost opportunity it sucks
so it sucks for like at all accounts for
us as prize that sucks for dads it sucks
for the industry but I I do think you
know health concerns are importance of
like you do it you know yeah you're
doctors but you know don't get sick and
die that's that's number one take care
of yourself don't not getting sick and
dying is way more important than the
make-believe things that we love and
digest real things I mean this is like I
mean but these people's lives to make
these things yeah oh yeah ultimately
your health and yeah life is more
important than anything yeah that's uh
but yeah that's it's unfortunate but you
know well still hat will still have
things to do bad Joe laughs she's always
fun though man I've never actually been
20:18 I met Yoko taro and I had him on a
livestream 29 Tina did the indie mix it
was cool as [ __ ] and we did the we went
to the mix event and like I have such
great memories with GGC I don't want it
to be GC parties are weird oh yeah I
don't doubt that at all and we should
GDC party once where Bob from Animal
Crossing the cat with
projected onto the wall yeah beautiful
yeah you know the vibes oh yeah blessed
be but on the note of events you Michael
just came back from PAX East yes which
was still on yes that's nice this
doesn't happen there were some
cancellations yeah right so some folks
pulled out and so did it yeah and I I
think it was the biggest one because we
were planning on seeing lots of us too
but we did see what was gonna be there
was probably gonna be the same stuff
that we saw at the last of us to preview
event that Jacob Dekker and Philip horn
Sean went to so I would use their full
name here why not give them no horn
maybe his bursaries just says Phil Jacob
who knows
mine's Kurt it's not Curtis okay I'm
gonna keep calling you Curtis Stone yeah
I get a lot of like what's Cali short
for I'm like California from music my
parents who had me in California named
me after the state I was born in shut up
Calista Flockhart oh that should be your
name is that a Final Fantasy that's not
like a filefast character Ally McBeal
uh-huh oh is it is that what it's from
that's the actresses horseshit Durrant
it's from time it's from Final Fantasy
well Jake Alistar FRA Flockhart Calista
the coolest report for Calliope it's
like my origin of the name oh it's taken
all of these names they're good anyways
just tell people that's what we're for
it was good anyway so Phil horn shut and
Jake Decker solace Austin but I didn't
because that Sony got out of PAX East
but there was still a lot to do I had a
great time at PAX East cuz I saw a lot
of dopey son Nicky mark
I saw Nicky mark shouts out to my boy
Nick margarita the most the most whitest
boy of New Jersey out there he's a piece
of [ __ ] and I love him to death
that's my guy
gamespot oh yeah Nick margarita was one
of our best friends in the office we
loved him he's he's doing business he
really is man he's living his best life
he's out there in New York - doing bangs
but yeah I got the say what's up - but
that was not for work PAX East man
I guess Calista Flockhart this happens
me every time I drink beer I always miss
anyway so one of the guns that you saw
was animal crossing new horizons and
while crossing new horizon I do want in
the interest of transparency to disclose
that I have the game and I have been
playing it so you will not talk I won't
be talking about it because I cannot
however you can talk about it because
you play some stuff that is not
embargoed I sure did I had to go see
Animal Crossing new horizons and what a
delightful game that is I saw some some
cool things it was on the show floor so
a lot of people were able to see this as
well but we got a little bit more of an
in-depth look at it and we got to peruse
the museum which is absolutely beautiful
the museum and Animal Crossing when
y'all start to play this game it's like
you always go through the motions of
collecting flop up digging up fossils
catching bugs catching fish and now it's
nice to see blathers and go to the
museum and best rap duo whistles of all
time but the whistles go but having this
like extravagant museum makes me want to
catch bugs and fish and all that good
stuff even more because it's it's so
beautifully laid out the aquarium is all
blue and [ __ ] and then it's it's like
multiple levels and it just looks so
nice in the biodome Firth all the bugs
is like very serene and peaceful they I
love hearing people talk about it on
crossings they talk about stuff like
that like the aquarium is blue and like
but it's there's just clearly like this
almost this it's like
toxicated nature over and I'm cross I'm
just making the mundane or then there
was something that's so normal
yeah beautiful and when you go timing
peaceful when you go to the exhibit for
all your fossils there are certain
points in the in the exhibit where the
camel camera will pull out and pan
around the museum so once you actually
collect all the fossils for a certain
dinosaur whatever you can see the full
picture of the fossils you collect this
is pretty like like it was just not like
that but you could you would always get
like fossils in three or two or three
pieces and you have to wait to complete
it yeah yeah so it's a little bit of
that and it's the museum is beautiful
also saw outfits outfits and fashion and
customisation for your character boy
mm-hmm yeah you got to see you get to do
some cool things got hat hair
accessories gonna have glasses sweaters
jackets you got a there's a maid outfit
you got a combat helmet I had a bath
towel on a combat helmet yeah yo it's
like it's like a World War 2 game but
it's been ages
I played the Gamecube one and now is
that was mine but ever since then it's
been it's been a bit yeah a bit for me
so yeah wild world every day for two
years can I get like a SWAT team even
for a minute now that I want it what
take it a leather jacket oh and for the
fashion I don't know yeah probably maybe
sick cuz you you while I had like the
World War two style helmet and then I
had a bath towel and see me look like a
crest pump big ol big old glasses you
can get different socks and shoes red
socks black boots that's all my name
yeah you can do that oh my god taxi
driver s know what I look like I don't
wanna look like yeah I mean when I said
cross plunks it's not that far off but I
mean it's a fit yeah after a pee break
we are back talking about a little
crossing new horizons so you were
talking about the fashion options so you
gotta sleep there's there's a lot of
options in the demo we saw of course
you're gonna it's gonna take a lot of
time to unlock all that stuff so
Nintendo had set things up to where
we had been able to fast-forward and got
to see all those things because we had
very limited time with it and there's a
lot of options man I'm really excited
for whoever if I ever get to the point
where I can have all those things it's
really I loved fashioning games like
Final Fantasy 14 is huge into glamour
for extra life 2019 we held an entire
costume contest a glamour contest in
Final Fantasy 14 for extra life I'm very
fascinated by the outfits that people
put together and animal crossing new
Rises is taking that to another level
because you could always customize like
hand draw your certain patterns and all
that and I know that what was we won was
a city folk and then we talked about
city fun oh really
hit them folk you know saying but yeah
the fashion options are great so I saw a
little bit of that it's all about the
museum and what was that there's a third
thing though yo you can snitch to Isabel
if you you can report your villagers for
wearing inappropriate and clothes or
singing inappropriate things words not
new but I was surprised by cuz like I
hadn't got that deep into previous
Animal Crossing games except for the
like the Gamecube one and wild world NTS
were we're huge but now it's it's just
it's just cute to be like and I seen
Isabel like Ashlee's losing it I'm sorry
but you said you could report your
villagers for wearing inappropriate
clothes unless you draw something on a
piece of clothing the way this worked in
previous Animal Crossing games is like
if you
I used to belong to an Animal Crossing
forums where people were like no pride
be like yeah be like oh come like I
does anyone have like turnips like
turnip prices and you can go to somebody
else's town and sell your turnips or
whatever if you talked to their
villagers there was a chance there those
villagers could move to your town and so
if you got somebody else's villagers and
they had like because you could like
choose your villagers catchphrases
sometimes they'd be like I need new
catchphrase and like if somebody had
been like penis hahaha and you had a
villager to come to your town and they'd
be like what's happening today penis
like you could go to Isabella be like
this villagers Wilin like ya dizzy has
like a really inappropriate yeah so then
what happens to them after you report
them I think it arrest whole town I
think just reset to their original
catchphrase yeah or their original
outfit so a lobotomy oh yeah
it's almost like you get a lot bottom e
and how you view them you can also just
be like I'm in like new leaf you could
be like Isabel I have an issue with a
visitor and like make your villagers
like forget somebody last episode I sing
break up and I restarted my town but I
should have just been like oh like we
don't know her holy [ __ ]
and we'll cross and get it get dark you
know saying it's just like for us the
entire time that you don't know them and
it's like oh yes I got the other way
like I mean it's a Nintendo game it's in
there basically just to protect children
but it feels cold it feels cold
sometimes kids need to be told like
don't like we just send them to an
island where you can't see them that's
exactly what you're doing and Animal
Crossing yeah do it in the demo yes I
stash on somebody I didn't get to see
what the what had come out of it because
it was a very short demo but that damn
hate to see ya but yeah Isabel
there she's adorable and I saw some of
the crafting stuff and what there was a
fifth thing
Tom nooks flight miles stay fly no lie
you notice ball you better like
achievements you just say you just put
words together no no I know you were
doing Jim Jones okay and then so it
looks like an achievement system where
you like do certain things and you get
rewards for it so it's another way of
rewarding you for just doing the things
that you do in Animal Crossing overall
when you get reward for snitching maybe
who knows and it gets a look through the
whole thing I'm sure they wouldn't
reward that that's in place just like
protect yourself oh yeah Animal Crossing
New Horizons is it's been a while since
I played an animal crossing game but
playing that at PAX East brought me back
to a very serene peaceful place because
the music is so adorable I love it I
love fashion and I like when you
wouldn't you because when you go to able
sister's shop you go into a dressing
room yeah I played I can't talk about
the demo I played yeah was just I start
like from the beginning of the game so
like none of this was in yeah so they I
love the way the able sisters shop is
set up this time around because you go
into a dressing room and it's it's a
menu with your character in the center
and you can just like pick and choose
whatever you want to try on and it's
immediately represented by your
character the middle and each time you
pick a new item they strike a new pose
and it's so cute they're like like no
the audio people that I was try striking
poses very cute pose he's adorable and
it looks so damn cute so you can you can
see your whole outfit that you want to
buy before you actually buy it and then
you'd be like okay I want to buy this
set that I put together boom buy it and
come out of the dressing room with it
it's a really efficient because I like
doing fashioning games and it's a little
bit clunky in like NBA 2k because you go
into the dress you've all gonna look
through a comparison
no real talk real talk like NBA 2k a
huge thing for like the my player thing
is fashion and going to the courts and
balling up and like the dopest Nike
joggers and like like like joggers or
maybe my body das yeah Feliz Navidad
arse low oh you're gonna love it
yes so the way the fashion thing self is
shot so the able sisters all y'all gonna
get all my bells imma spend it all there
once I get around to it speaking of
bells did you see that story going
around today about the the belly anair
thought that name was the footies bloody
bail-ins Wow about the Belgian air
oh the the the Animal Crossing
speedrunner he's finally about to hit a
billion I don't know if it's a healing
bit they're finally about to hit a
billion bells and I think the gamecube
version I felt this headline this
morning on Bart so my details are fuzzy
hmm I'm surprised that they actually
didn't put a cap like usually usually
nine nine nine in Pokemon the cat is
nine hundred not nine million
are you sure I thought was 900 and you
would know better than me but I thought
you told me yeah because I hit the cap
trying to get the [ __ ] flame orb
which I finally got because they added
it in in a event anyone who makes more
than 10 million dollars should be taxed
at 70 percent anything they make over 10
million dollars you know I'm saying it's
coming from mr. Poole it'll be a game
yesterday was Super Tuesday so it's just
that's at the top of mind
so anyway anything else do you want to
talk about backsies before we move on Oh
last question aside from Animal Crossing
she dreams elsewhere there that is a
game from Bob Boyd aviom good in its
undertale meets persona I talked a
little bit about it in our pack C's
video damn it's very impressive and
Davion good and he is putting a lot of
his own like he's a lot of putting a lot
of his own his own stank on it when it
cuz he's almost like I'm gonna rub yo
I'm gonna develop a game and I'm just
gonna rub my stank on it man Jake says
it all time it just means to put your ol
like personal twist on things and I'm
really I'm really impressed with that
game because of how it's it's really
cool I like you should check it out she
dreams elsewhere it's an RPG it's it has
a lot of like styling uh persona
stylings but it has a lot of undertale
vibes from it's like art style and it's
like the perspective you have in
constant shacking question but oh yeah
let's that's that that's the that is the
number one game I saw and one more game
that I saw there's two games to sit out
and the other one is star renegades
roguelike RPG I think it's roguelike RPG
and it's the combat system is very
complex everything and then really
quickly you've also seen doom in turn
always yeah I guess we don't know other
people you have content yeah Jake and I
did a bunch of content for do meter it
looks weird
thanks uh anyway to give you all the
this the quick rundown of we Jake and I
went to Texas to see go to ed software
we saw a 2-meter no we played battle
mode and I'm impressed with battle mode
because of
how much the so the way it is is 1v2
asymmetrical multiplayer and uh we got
one doom Slayer gets two demons doom
Slayer plays exactly like it does in
single-player so you thought that muscle
memory still shows through cool when you
play as in player and the multiplayer so
just still doing the same things glory
kills chainsaw kills flamethrower you're
still cycling through your weapons scale
demons and your objective is to kill the
two player control demons very hard
because the demons on that on their side
have can spawning minions they have
special powers they have different
attacks they all move differently
because you could say on roles of five
different demons so they work like
different character classes ooh then you
have to outsmart doom Slayer who's just
like ripping and tearing through all the
demons that you spoke on there good time
and it is like we've seen asymmetrical
multiplayer in a bunch of other games
but it's I don't think it's ever done it
this tightly in this sharply before
because the foundation of Doom is very
strong to begin with so they're coming
from a strong place already for this and
I don't know if it's gonna like hit for
everyone but what may they hit exactly
what they're going for the multiplayer
in the first one was boxed and it was
nothing to write home about
yeah there's deathmatch yeah whether you
like this or not you have to at least
give it to them if they're trying
something different and they're
executing on their vision it's extremely
well
the - hunter prey multiplayer thing they
added like asymmetric yeah sure
the functions a little different but the
idea is kind of yeah similar I'm
intrigued by I mean I love doom yeah and
I played a new single-player mission
it's very good boss fight at the end you
can watch some fire ass gameplay on
games good I also I was watching it this
might be sacrilegious I was watching it
without headphones at first just to see
what was flowing and then I was like nah
I am just as excited for that soundtrack
as I am the game because I listen to I
probably put more hours listening to the
doom to admit Gordon soundtrack then I
have actually playing the game so I put
my headphones on to listen to the
soundtrack with that video and GameSpot
and it is
tight yeah aye man every time I've seen
doom eternal multiple times at this
point every time it continues to impress
me with something new that is can't wait
so far from what I've seen in preview
form is has been impressive and
incredible I'm excited to see what other
people think of it once it comes out
there because man like I love shooters
but I was more of like a tactical
shooter kind of person like oh yeah I
played a lot of arena shooters in my
life but you know I aim and then I move
aim and I move but there's something
they have there's a lot of systems in
place that make you think a little bit
more and I like what they're doing
really like really quickly because I
don't think anybody here has had the
time to play it the Final Fantasy 7
remake demo was released I plays I want
to play it so bad but I just not had
time I I think we might we could
probably save like a deeper discussion
for next week
obviously Ashley you're a Final Fantasy
person have you spent any time with it
uh well unfortunately the demo released
when I was here oh right yeah my ps4 is
sadly at home and it's not even on rest
mode and I won't even ask my roommate to
try to download it because she will have
no idea what she's doing Oh play the
demo but I think at this point I'm gonna
kind of treat it like how I do with a
lot of movies I want to see which is
like wait I actually don't I try to
avoid the trailer wait the demo I just
want to like go in blind and just do it
cuz it looks great yeah I've played
Final Fantasy 7 remake at events past
and this is the devil is an extended
version of that and it dropped on Sunday
right when pax ended and pax the 7
remake was playable for the first time
to the public at taxi keep saying PAX
West I think but it was but yeah it was
playable for the first time publicly
early max least we're doing a spongebob
singing what's the spongebob thing no
idea we're talking about
wit Patrick start doesn't understand
that the W stands for West and he says
it's least least Jake would know what
I'm talking we stood
okay keep going seven we make demos out
you should play because every I think
seven remake is shaping up to be
extremely cool
there's also bunch of content on gangsta
Montcalm by Edmund Tran and people need
to put respect on Edmund trans name you
know her saying he likes star Louis
being a madman Tran I just reminded me
of my know it makes me think about all
my Asian folk out there um at PAX East
there Victoria Tran not related to Edna
Tran but she's a homegirl who's working
on game she works for Kip Fox but she
had panel about disappointing her ethnic
parents by being in the gaming industry
wonderful panel shots let's my homegirl
and Edmund Tran does that in Australia
that same panel but he holds it down for
Australia wonderful panel so shout out
to all of my ethnics I'm saying
hell yeah dude and Chris and I'm
intranalyze Grim Fandango so that's cool
I'm saying anyway question mark question
mark is what was written down here there
were some surprise yeah Alex drops
because the the surprise was like no I
mean valve kind of does this thing where
they don't really say anything was like
call their own shots and then we were
like whoa damn this is halfway box of
gameplay we have we've complied there's
three separate videos but we've compiled
them all into one huge ball so you check
that out but this is the first half-life
game in thirteen years so it's a big
deal yeah yeah I'm saying oh yeah as a
half-life fan I will say I think like
the first chunk of that gameplay footage
it was one of those things where I was
watching this and was like I need I it
was not exciting to watch and that's how
I felt and I think it's one of those
things where it's like I need to tell
myself I it's one of those things and
I'm fortunate for the viewer this for
some viewers were I'm not gonna really
this game until I'm playing it because
it is VR and because just watching
someone interact and do things VR is
such a it's different it's such a
specific experience that you have you
know how you maneuver things I will say
the last gunfight of that video was
[ __ ] awesome I thought that fight
kicked ass and that like really really
showed me like a good way of how there's
like a part when Alex when the player is
a duck man a van like uses the door of
the van open it the bonfire and like
moments like that wall like the player
was like attaching things to the gun
while also fighting other people is like
that's the stuff I'm excited experience
but that gameplay footage it's just hard
for me because I also don't play a lot
of VR games yeah so what as someone who
has followed VR since its public
inception into since 2016 there's always
the thing with the VR has always been
like Oh every game it comes out so I go
to tech demo or they're trying to prove
a concept I am that's kind of all it
does I mean VR has come a long way since
then but watching half-life Alex in
action this is the probably the the
either the first time or the the time
that I've seen all of those concepts
come together as one and there are some
like narrative driven games where you
explore the environment you get a but
doesn't really have like in-depth combat
but here is kind of all of those
elements that you've seen evolve through
VR are finally coming into one game and
if that makes me excited for for
half-life alex is I play a lot of VR
games and I've been impressed with
certain aspects of them but not the
whole mmm-hmm this is the one that looks
like the reasons I'm hoping joining the
VR boat yeah naturally are horse that's
why I'm getting a headset you know so
I'm this game Alex and wagon and I'm the
horse the VR headset it's like riding a
place like those cows he's like you see
this Ettore about the cows that are
living in this VR world - making out
here I'm riding on a horse that's in the
VR headset that makes it feel like okay
is where the cows is like a farm yeah
yes we're dead bodies aren't you taking
sandwiches from their bodies oh my god
Richard that's all I got I said that's
all we got and then that's that all that
baton that we're gonna move on to
listener questions you can email us at
after dark podcast at gamespot.com if
you want to ask us questions about
really anything we get all sorts of
emails you we don't need any more spam
emails though so stop with that if
you're one of those spam people but also
if you're trying to shoot news at us
don't say this first question hey listen
GAD crew like G sad better guess what
happens yeah always
hey listen GAD crew I woke up this
morning craving some zealot talk from
y'all it is a series not without some
controversies which is the jump from
Zelda 1 Zelda to wind wakers graphical
debut skyward swords motion controls and
breadth of the wilds open-world slash
dungeon design thoughts favorite moments
what the top five list looked like to
you for my part Link's Awakening taught
me the series game language such as rock
walls movable what's going on or she was
looking at explodes this is a lot
burning bushes to me the franchise was
getting lackluster in the GameCube in
the game human we era but won me back
with breath of the wild thanks a bunch
Nick from Florida PS what is your best
impersonation of the Zelda - game over
Ganon laugh never played them - so I
can't help you there but I can't go Rob
said Rob man Larry does a very good
piece one episode of this podcast where
all of you were just saying his lines
you're doing Dutch van der Linde Arthur
Morgan I feel like I've trained with
square wheels like um anyways anyways so
a top-five list of Zelda games for me I
mean I I always categorize I have to
like the caveat is 2d Zelda versus 3d
Zelda I think they're different okay I
had a point I think of them differently
I really looked breath of the wild my
personal favorites all does majora's
mask then probably winwaker then breath
of the wild then
link to the past then no mmm
see later look it's like I had to put
link to the past over on a different
it's just not the same yeah it's hard to
compare them yeah but I will say wind
wakers graphics are phenomenal Toon Link
is best ink and everybody was wrong yeah
it's aged
I love Skyward Sword I refuse to play
it's messed up hot take I like Skyward
Sword
that's not take IGN gave it a 10 well I
feel like it's a hot take among Zelda I
guess like if I move I feel like it's
it's it's fairly common to to meet
people who see for me don't like it more
than they like it I just hate the air
itself yeah yeah
top 5 Zelda's for me let me see off the
top of the brain let's see
winwaker number 1 majora's mask number 2
number 3 would have to be [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] breath a while for ocarina time 5
is Link's Awakening noir oh sorry link
to the past
yeah I would I were probably dealing for
the past then ocarina oh yeah ocarina
was a little bit more formative for me
yeah then I went to link to the past or
I had Linda passing I had my brother's
save so I'd already like I was just
walking around like chopping [ __ ] down
I'm like I don't really get it play
ocarina time was I will that's wild and
then I suppose say I like spirit tracks
and I even enjoyed Phantom Hourglass
so I actually haven't played a ton of
Zelda games there's like a strange gap
for me um but the only ones I did play
which are less than 5 obviously I think
breath of the wild is the one that I put
the most time in only because you know
it's newer and I managed to get into it
even though I really thought I wouldn't
because again the after that for me is
majora's mask which i love because it's
creepier it's weirder but it's also so
much more stressful than breath of the
world oh my god
and then you know after that I feel like
ocarina of time cuz it is a classic and
then the only other game I played please
don't ask me why I don't remember but
Phantom Hourglass I played and you know
what
was pretty enjoyable that the games are
right but like spirit tracks way more
than okay okay but I got I just love
tune links so I went on the I yeah I
went on this whole journey I've never
played Twilight Princess I saw somebody
play a little bit of it I saw a wolf
mm-hmm a weird thing but the wolf was
lost in the sewers for a long time and
then this is when I was watching my old
roommate play and then there was
something with a lot of goats and then I
don't I was like why are you why are you
playing this game where you're spending
like 20 minutes on this weird goat
minigame yeah it's the horse I think you
I think it's been a bit but it's like
you you you're it's like a horse
minigame you're trying to get the really
gather yeah yeah sure I heard them that
game just came out during a time where
he didn't play a lot of games so for me
I didn't own an n64 growing up so I
played ocarina of time late I played
Majora's Mask late but I did play a lot
of early zelda games including zelda 2
is actually probably put a lot of time
into as a little dude what but even
though iíve played a lot of the earlier
ones i don't know if it's like what it
is but i gravitated towards the later
ones
so like twilight princess for me is like
probably my favourite one breath of the
wild
I haven't played Link's Awakening the
the remake that's really cute but I've
played the original so that'd probably
be number three then I Creina
and then I've never completed majora's
mask because I had to give I was bargain
at 64 and borrowing it but that one has
always been the one that was like I want
to get through that I want to beat that
one but that's number five for me even
though I haven't finished it so maybe
that's messed up I get it but I don't
think you have to finish every game to
like to say you liked it it's just one
of those ones where it's like I it's I
honestly feel like it could be number
one but I can't say that because I
haven't completed it and it's just like
there's parts the parts that experience
that game was like
I love love love this but I've never had
the opportunity to finish it so I played
Majora's Mask really - I played it on
3ds it's alright
properly played Ocarina for the first
time on 3ds I it was a time when like we
rented a lot of games instead of buying
them because that was yeah when you're
you're my parents were like they had
their games that they wanted to buy and
play and then like if I wanted to game
and be like well she may or may not like
it yeah so we rented Ocarina and I
distinctly remember I'm having a really
hard time like getting past certain
things I when I was a young and I think
I had the walkthrough I just didn't
understand languages ah yeah I think
that there's LD games like when I tried
to play ocarina of time for the first
time it was it seemed like to me the
franchise even at that time already I
think I was like probably like 12 or
something that it felts I don't know why
impenetrable to me that it seems like
there was a way or like way of thinking
that Zelda players have adopted like
when they go through these games so like
an example that I usually use is like I
do a lot of like New York Times
crossword puzzles but the thing is is
that everyone's a goal you must be
really smart look not it's also about
adopting like there's a certain way or
certain answers you're a certain way of
thinking that you get used to so
actually it really isn't super difficult
later and I think it might be there or I
felt that it was the same with Zelda and
that like when I finally looked it up
you know like on game facts or whatever
and I was like how the hell you use all
this and they're like oh you you stand
here and then like you shoot an arrow
into a hole on the other side and I was
like what hole what yeah you know and
they're like oh well it's over there and
then like once I read that I was like
hah I'm like by 12 year old brain I'm
sure it was like already you know
cursing extensively by this point I was
just like how the [ __ ] was I supposed to
know that yeah like no those in
crossword puzzles so now that I think
like you know I'm like okay so maybe if
I played more Zelda games it wouldn't
have been as difficult for me to start
yeah I think Ocarina of Time is a weird
one to start with yeah like that was
technically my first Alda game but it is
it's there's a lot of stuff in ocarina
of time that like if you don't know the
language of Zelda you're gonna be like
the princess has some of that yeah
answer cards to Knicks point like Link's
Awakening I think if you play the remake
I think Link's Awakening is a super good
way to get the language of Zelda oh
that's so funny because Link's Awakening
was technically my first Zelda game on
the Gameboy that my cousin gave me is
like wow I'm not playing this why are
you and I I'm gonna just say it right
now it's too stupid to understand what
the hell's going on I put it and I was
like oh my god this is so cool and he's
like washed up on shore there's cool
like beach noises coming from my gameboy
I'm like this is dope this is great and
then I couldn't get past the trees and I
was like let's turn this off and never
played it again
yeah I mean I did there was ocarina of
time but I was like five so yeah because
I'm young I guess bro little we're all
young yet Waker is the go time um put
Wind Waker HD on switch to princess and
lick flicking winwaker please movies
which okay moving on hello after dark
actually Michael you only this one oh
sure yeah hello after dark crew just a
simple question for you oh that's called
bars you remember of the Animal Crossing
universe you wake up one day and decide
that you have had enough of Tom nooks
monopolistic [ __ ] today today
monopolistic grasp on Commerce in the
world there's a very polite way of
saying it how do you structure a
business that can compete to take orth
that can compete or take him down
Thanks wholesome Jacob aka Jacob McCourt
that's wholesome Jacob because Jake
Decker is evil Jacob he's a sushi oh boy
yeah let me see um so I just want to say
I love this question um my answer would
to be to form a villager co-op and put
the the means of production in the hands
of the animals and seize the means of
production I think you could say it
better than that that was you know I'm
not gonna make my own business I'm going
to to like we're gonna have free health
care in my village he's an entrepreneur
let him rule
that's not my regular Tom Nook I'm just
kidding what do you guys think of the
take that's going around that Tom Nook
is actually a good landlord because he
has no deadlines no interest it's a take
I mean that as in you can pay whenever
you want yeah people are like you know
the narrative is like Tom nooks a crook
because he's like the the you know the
Money holder in the Animal Crossing
universe however Tom Nook has his loans
have no interest and no deadlines and
basically no credit limit or any I mean
that means that you're never gonna pay a
rent I mean never really have to exactly
he never comes knocking on your door
like yo you finna get evicted yeah so
what's the initiative to
I think you want to upgrade because it's
human nature to do that exactly because
I'm trying to say like without it we
probably wouldn't my problem with Tom
milk is that he puts you in just his
true situations that you didn't ask for
like I asked for this this is this Bell
Det you bloody Bell and he's like hmm
we've just upgraded your house Congrats
on paying off your loan however did you
ever think you'd have enough space yeah
he's one he's one of those guys I'm like
you know he's not the worst but he's
still bad
you know Sam so wholesome Jacob I would
say that I probably shouldn't give my
true opinion on this because it's too
political
number one air B&B type thing for my
house so it's like all pocket the money
that these tourists and then fight fire
with fire
that's call adapting more aggressive out
of my wheelhouse I don't care
cryptocurrency move away from bells yeah
I just move out go through another
Island yeah it turns out he's spilled on
me and the rest of the villagers were
unionized yeah like Timmy and Tommy like
I guess it's about your wages yeah I
mean that's the fight you want to fight
and it's just like I don't got time for
that Isabel how much are you making
there's no taxes yeah you know what mate
is your salary how much do you think
Isabel makes for free dude oh dude
volunteer dude doesn't she do you see
that post where it's like clearly she
just wears Gucci he's not one but two
Gucci sweaters yeah where'd you get that
from Spain for that Bank
I think she's selling fruit outside mmm
yeah um thank you wholesome Jacob and
actually we had a big pee break drama
this episode but I forgot at the end of
last week's episode we all were like we
have to finish the episode because we're
all gonna pee our pants so this person
says hello after dark crew I hope
everyone on last week's episode made it
to the toilet and that everyone's
kidneys are safe this is actually from
February 21st what day is it today
was that last week so it was it the one
with Dave Klein in Peter Brown
I don't know no Lucy was there and we
had to pee really bad anyway I think
there's a common reoccurring thing we
drink beer every episode yes question
so so this is from Robert J rapper Jay
has two questions what game difficulty
do you all usually play and what
difficulty you pick when reviewing a
game thanks for reading and have a
lovely day sincerely Robert JPS I'm
sorry for all the commas I used
incorrectly in any of my previous emails
that's because we had a question that
was like what makes you angry Aston
Peter was like Kelly yours is misused
commas and I was like you know you're
right okay so what difficulty you guys
play on normal and normal for RPGs it's
hard to tell what the difficulty spikes
are like and older RPGs don't let you
change difficulty on the fly so I just
go into them playing normal most
recently persona 3 has a problem with
its difficulty spikes but still love
that game but I think something like
doom or so I wouldn't play call duty
single-player on a harder difficulty
because of the way that game is
structured but the way Doom is
structured I would play that on a harder
difficulty because you know what the
variables are the yeah when games make
the variables of difficulty very clear I
am more willing to play the game on
they're harder difficulty when they
leave that those things up as a mystery
or if it leads to cheap [ __ ] [ __ ] it I'm
playing on normal yeah you know vibes
for reviews usually I'll just do normal
yeah and I think it really depends on
the game if I want to choose a harder
difficulty I think like I just have to
guess depending on the game I think
unfortunately the last miss diagnosis
that's the only word I can think of is
for Wolfenstein actually yeah I know a
lot of people had that and I feel like
that so the new or what not Youngblood
new closet.you Colossus I feel like was
much harder than new order and just like
this is a regular yeah that's fight you
do you bring up new classes specifically
because I'm playing through doom a
nightmare not ultra nightmare but I
started also playing through Wolfenstein
two new classes again on the hardest
difficulty and it is unreasonably hard I
mean maybe like I thought I was gonna be
fine cuz I was tearing through not the
brag through do my nightmare but the
moment with the new Colossus and I was
it was like one shot kills on me and I
was like I don't know I can't and
covering systems are way more complex in
that game than doom is so it's not like
you can run jump gun and fly around the
place where you Colossus you you you get
to a point where you're just kind of in
a corner and you're just ducking around
certain areas we're trying shoot through
people I think tries to combine the
whole like with doom like you said it's
so easy to just sort of like run and gun
and get a bunch of a game encouraging
and like it Wolfenstein does but it also
forces you to be a little bit tactical
about it but only I feel like at the
last minute or like something just like
you still in the wheelchair and you have
to plain that opening part in the
hardest difficulty was like it was like
maybe I'm not that good a game and I
played it on I typically review games on
normal just to get them on standardized
exactly but that one I reviewed on the
like the level above the level the
standard one just cuz I was like I play
a lot of shooters I I can handle it and
I did I played it on that difficulty the
whole way through but like I I was
like ooh this is mess yeah and then when
I reviewed the switch version because
that version made me so motion sick I
had to drop it down like in you know
handheld I I always start like medium or
normal if I'm reviewing a game
I'll always start the same and then I'll
go and test the heart it's difficult to
see what it's like Fire Emblem is a good
example of a game that I wish I started
on hard that game you got like if you're
just starting fire on them three houses
yeah always will always recommend doing
it on casual which is not permit death
but on hard yeah if you are not used to
Fire Emblem instead of doing classic
with perma death yeah well do casual and
hard yeah
so I wish I started that game that way
but normally start a normal or medium
and if I really like that game and I'm
going to play it again I will always
step it up and go harder so or in the
case here's our in the case that I
really don't like the game and I but I
feel obligated to finish it so I can
articulate easy better opinion I'll
knock it down easy there's a few games
I've done that with which might be
controversial because I was like I just
need to finish this game and I put on
easy Bioshock was one of them where I
played it late and I was like strike I
just need to finish this and I put on
easy just a blast through it to see it
to the end yeah I mean I I always
encourage my reviewers to I mean the
thing is like I feel like games
increasingly the game's life freelance
out don't have difficulty modes at all
yeah I feel like Fire Emblem is the one
I can think I guess Call of Duty I think
i reviewed Call of Duty unhardened today
I don't know modern warfare was actually
harder than I expected it's pretty hard
but I just I can't think of a lot like
there's a lot of games that review that
don't have to like all Nintendo games
like Nintendo games don't have
difficulty yeah besides fire alone and
fire but might review that came on
normal and I was just like this is a
burries okay yeah and I still haven't
tried the whatever the one above heart I
want to started a new file I because of
that I've only done two runs
do I need to do the dlc and I haven't
done a golden deer run I think for doom
eternal I might start on a harder
difficulty yes just because I I'm gonna
do my no doom I know this that this doom
is a lot different and throws a lot of
different things into it but I think I
might start on a hardwood Dan doom
eternal is very good at teaching you
what it is you need to know okay and
then it doesn't leave anything up to
mystery
it just says this is what you need to go
and do it well okay and I've been first
plated on normal during the first
preview that I went soon the second
preview was like I could play this on
harder and then because I already knew
what I needed to do and it's really
rewarding it's a lot tougher difficulty
balance is good yeah like coming
especially playing doom and the new
Colossus back to back playing doom a
nightmare like I said it's like I it
felt fair and it's hard like I felt like
I was like I don't know what how to play
this differently personally two must be
better at the game so I love new classes
so much I love that game that game is
excellent
probably in my top 5 game so much I just
I mean I wrote as a Murphy I just loved
one thing I love about new classes is
just like never less you forget but like
the Nazis are evil and you should be
fighting them yeah like I just think
that has done so well like you when you
go into like nuke doubt Manhattan that
was just like the courtroom scene all
that game is I mean even like the
opening wheelchair sequences like what
game has a relationship with your mother
PJ blaskowitz the is the is the furthest
from a him bow he is a he is a
attractive hot level-headed he is no
he's caring he's a pathetic yeah he
hates Nazis what else he's a good man to
his to to the women in his life he cares
about his mom you know a feature really
wanted to do is top 10 daddies in gaming
and it really just goes garel BJ
blaskowitz and those are the only ones
BJ I've before I worked here and I was
like I had I had a blog and I was like
trying to learn how to write I had a
whole thing about PJ blaskowitz just
being like this is it like this game
this do
food is the epitome of the macho
muscular like stereotype Action Hero
but turn out its head because there's
such beautiful emotional moments where
it's like turn out Ted I just feel like
it's like if the doom Slayer were
injected with emotions yeah exactly it's
kinda like what they did a Kratos and
like BG still feels it's like the Kratos
has more I think a more emotional depth
the Kratos has the edge of a hardened
sort of bitter dad when BJ BJ is a daddy
yeah Kratos I feel like tries harder he
tried harder to get cuz where he but BJ
doesn't cuz he's just because he's got
some rhythms Forks mm-hmm new classes
there's one scene that I just I think
about every time I yeah powerful
powerful woman there anyway that's
probably a good place that's well
actually I do want to say that the game
the difficulty you play games on does
not matter though because whatever works
for you works for you um we just tried
standardized it I think is the kind of
the mood of this group uh a few game
you're a gamer
hell yeah that's it and that's bad on
that anyway thank you so much for
joining us for games part after drug i
didn't say what episode this was this is
good plug if anybody yeah so before we
go
Kurt is there anything you'd like to
plug hi I'm Kurt and Davina and I'm here
to plug a show called remember when
it's coming out this Monday at 4 a.m. Pt
March
what's Monday today is the force of 9th
March 9th is the release of Ashoka
yes it is anyways we have a new show
coming out called remember when and I'm
very very excited about it
pretty much elevator pitch is that it is
a kind of a history show I like to
describe it as a do-it-yourself
nostalgia it is about old stories in
gaming history told with new
perspectives from personalities here in
the office and beyond and the first
episode we're launching is about the
hadouken and the importance of the
hadouken and it's told through people
like Jeff Gerstmann and temor Hussein
and Chasteen we also have other faces
like John choy who was a little it was a
legendary Hadouken master as well as say
Jim who was a commentator so we have a
variety of faces and personalities and
it's all kind of packaged together with
this do-it-yourself kind of DIY same
thing feeling but kind of like an ATM
machine yeah ATM what does ATM stands
for automated teller machine that
machines yeah there's a joke because you
said a redundant thing anyway I'm not
smart enough I'm sorry Kelly Kelly's
trough her freckle heart anyways that's
my big plug take that with plug it in um
play Final Fantasy 8 yeah
and follow games yeah do that
we Michael you could follow me and all
of our [ __ ] at Michael P hi I'm on
Twitter
that's my plug and also I got yo I'm mr.
worldwide out here I'm channeling my
inner pitbull energy I've been going to
a lot of events I have a lot of coverage
doom eternal and by the time this goes
up I'll have some coverage on Animal
Crossing and I am playing some games and
I will be playing some games that can't
talk about quite yet but they will be on
the site March is the busiest month of
my life god help me March
I mean it's already March but it's it's
um I mean I don't like gods out there
but if you are Gogu if you're out there
like help us know saying yeah lots of
good stuff and you know my co-workers
here at GameSpot always put out good
[ __ ] on GameSpot calm falses put that
[ __ ] as your homepage bro what y'all
doing gamespot calm and oh yeah oh it
mine is at it's Ashley I was an IT s
Ashley oh I'm not just saying it's at
Ashley oh it is not it is at it's Ashley
oh please decipher this message and also
at GameSpot oh my god but no she said
personal right whatever I mean you could
actually at GameSpot please strong Evans
gonna kill us watch we put our handle at
hurt underscore in Davina K u RT not see
at sea [ __ ] no I'm messing it at ke u RT
underscore IND o VI na and then Davina
chef boyardee you can now watch the full
competitive Pokemon mini-series on
GameSpot's YouTube that I've been
talking about for like two months
Jake and I don't put all of that out
it'll teach you about Pokemon stats some
major battle stuff and also how to breed
an Eevee training Pokemon it's like more
of a it's like a primer so it's not
gonna go into like really complicated
Eevee stuff or crazy really good as a
non Pokemon a competitor boy I learned
stuff I did my best and Jake did the
most you did a lot of graphics take a
watch that and then obviously always
read GameSpot reviews cuz I edit them
and I'm really proud of our reviews and
I hope that you read them and you can
follow me on Twitter at Genki tojiko i
nky do ji kko and that was episode 30 of
GameSpot after dark we will see you next
week
we're about to have a actually pretty
exciting next couple weeks of episodes
so keep an eye out there's a lot
surprises in store a special guest in a
couple weeks ma made special guest we
got a lot of stuff planned
look forward to that and we'll see you
next time and if there's anything else I
forgot you can complain to me at after
our podcast at Gamescom bayi
thank you so much please
[Music]
[Music]